[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have our
first look at the upcoming spider-man
Miles Morales game throughout this video
we're going to be giving our thoughts on
it and discussing some of the things
that you might have missed there may be
some spoilers here so if you don't
anything ruined and I highly recommend
that you turn off now make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day
and please Amy a little web-shooter
right that thumbs up button if you enjoy
the video without the way thank you for
clicking this and let's play the trailer
before we get into our reaction a hero
is just someone who doesn't give up
your dad said that he was right
now it's your turn go be a hero miles
okay
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
okay so the trailer opens with Peter
pretty much passing the mantle for miles
you might remember in the spider-man ps4
game that mild his father actually died
as part of the plot and then miles
developed his abilities and and Peter
sort of became his mentor I'm so glad we
don't have any more of those stealth
sections again as they completely sucked
but yeah it's good to see him he's gonna
be swinging around the city and the
footage looks absolutely incredible I'm
not sure if my capturing software here
quite shows off just how fancy it is but
yeah watching his suit get torn up is
absolutely amazing now what's
interesting about this suit getting torn
up is that miles of course has these
electrical abilities but it doesn't look
like he can actually control them and
thus it's sort of backfiring onto
himself in spider-man into the spider
verse he of course learned to master
these but here it's just completely
ravaging his suit from head to toe now
one of the best things about this video
is seeing the spider-man mask and then
his face come out from behind it the
spider-man mask is you know often being
associated with Peter Parker but seeing
miles his face tear through it it's
really symbolic that this is the new
direction that they're going in I think
it's absolutely amazing that they're
giving Miles his own game and this is
one step closer to us getting a live
action miles which I just really really
want to see we then get him swinging
through the city which it looks very
similar to the ps4 game I know this is
meant to be captured on PS 5 and I
wasn't too overwhelmed by the graphics
but I know that Sonya aiming more
towards games and gameplay rather than
just pure graphics we see him doing a
rescue mission and it looks amazing I'm
guessing this is gonna be a QuickTime
event but it just plays out so
beautifully he also gets attacked by
someone who seems to have an electrified
invisible weapon miles his powers are of
course electricity and invisibility so
yeah this is a nice counter action for
his moves I'm not too up on miles as
villains and his rogues gallery so if
you know who this is then make sure you
let me know below the game also seems to
be taking place in winter predominantly
so it's gonna be a nice change up and
yet New York just looks absolutely
beautiful covered in snow miles is then
seen jumping through the air and he
turns invisible which is one of his main
power sets his hand also powers up with
the electricity so it does look like he
mastered
this skill throughout the game the
police chasin happens and it's good to
see him rubbing shoulders with the old
boys in blue his father was of course a
policeman so yeah I like that he's still
kind of working with them
Milan does some more electrical attacks
and finally he unmasks to show his face
now what's amazing about this game is
that it's coming out this yeah so we
don't have to wait too long
2020s kind of been kicking the teeth but
I'm just so glad to see this now it's a
very short trailer but I was completely
blown away by it and I wasn't really too
sure and whether I would cover this
event but to see this as one of the
trailers I just got about with bed went
downstairs turn on my laptop and and
just gave my thoughts and I'm
freestyling at the moment and just going
off the top of my head but I really
really enjoyed it and it's pretty much
made me have to buy a ps5 now now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer so comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and if you want
something else that's Marvel related to
watch that make sure you check out our
breakdown of Captain America the Winter
Soldier we go over a lot of things that
you missed in the movie and I guarantee
that there's so many Easter eggs in
there that you haven't spotted before if
you want to support the channel from as
little as a 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow so heavy
spoilers or click the disc or link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with us so
hopefully we see over there very soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]